In this lecture, we're going to use the circuit
pipelining techniques we learned in Part 1
of the course to improve the performance of
the 32-bit Beta CPU design we developed in
Part 2 of the course.
This CPU design executes one Beta instruction
per clock cycle.
Hopefully you remember the design!
If not, you might find it worthwhile to review
Lecture 13, Building the Beta, from Part 2.
At the beginning of the clock cycle, this
circuit loads a new value into the program
counter, which is then sent to main memory
as the address of the instruction to be executed
this cycle.
When the 32-bit word containing the binary
encoding of the instruction is returned by
the memory, the opcode field is decoded by
the control logic to determine the control
signals for the rest of the data path.
The operands are read from the register file
and routed to the ALU to perform the desired
operation.
For memory operations, the output of the ALU
serves as the memory address and, in the case
of load instructions, the main memory supplies
the data to be written into the register file
at the end of the cycle.
PC+4 and ALU values can also be written to
the register file.
The clock period of the Beta is determined
by the cumulative delay through all the components
involved in instruction execution.
Today's question is: how can we make this
faster?
We can characterize the time spent executing
a program as the product of three terms.
The first term is the total number of instructions
executed.
Since the program usually contains loops and
procedure calls, many of the encoded instructions
will be executed many times.
We want the total count of instructions executed,
not the static size of the program as measured
by the number of encoded instructions in memory.
The second term is the average number of clock
cycles it takes to execute a single instruction.
And the third term is the duration of a single
clock cycle.
As CPU designers it's the last two terms which
are under our control: the cycles per instruction
(CPI) and the clock period (t_CLK).
To affect the first term, we would need to
change the ISA or write a better compiler!
Our design for the Beta was able to execute
every instruction in a single clock cycle,
so our CPI is 1.
As we discussed in the previous slide, t_CLK
is determined by the longest path through
the Beta circuitry.
For example, consider the execution of an
OP-class instruction, which involves two register
operands and an ALU operation.
The arrow shows all the components that are
involved in the execution of the instruction.
Aside from a few muxes, the main memory, register
file, and ALU must all have time to do their
thing.
The worst-case execution time is for the LD
instruction.
In one clock cycle we need to fetch the instruction
from main memory (t_IFETCH),
read the operands from the register file (t_RF),
perform the address addition in the ALU (t_ALU),
read the requested location from main memory
(t_MEM),
and finally write the memory data to the destination
register (t_WB).
The component delays add up and the result
is a fairly long clock period and hence it
will take a long time to run the program.
And our two example execution paths illustrate
another issue:
we're forced to choose the clock period to
accommodate the worst-case execution time,
even though we may be able to execute some
instructions faster since their execution
path through the circuitry is shorter.
We're making all the instructions slower just
because there's one instruction that has a
long critical path.
So why not have simple instructions execute
in one clock cycle and more complex instructions
take multiple cycles instead of forcing all
instructions to execute in a single, long
clock cycle?
As we'll see in the next few slides, we have
a good answer to this question, one that will
allow us to execute *all* instructions with
a short clock period.
We're going to use pipelining to address these
issues.
We're going to divide the execution of an
instruction into a sequence of steps, where
each step is performed in successive stages
of the pipeline.
So it will take multiple clock cycles to execute
an instruction as it travels through the stages
of the execution pipeline.
But since there are only one or two components
in each stage of the pipeline, the clock period
can be much shorter and the throughput of
the CPU can be much higher.
The increased throughput is the result of
overlapping the execution of consecutive instructions.
At any given time, there will be multiple
instructions in the CPU, each at a different
stage of its execution.
The time to execute all the steps for a particular
instruction (i.e., the instruction latency)
may be somewhat higher than in our unpipelined
implementation.
But we will finish the last step of executing
some instruction in each clock cycle, so the
instruction throughput is 1 per clock cycle.
And since the clock cycle of our pipelined
CPU is quite a bit shorter, the instruction
throughput is quite a bit higher.
All this sounds great, but, not surprisingly,
there are few issues we'll have to deal with.
There are many ways to pipeline the execution
of an instruction.
We're going to look at the design of the classic
5-stage instruction execution pipeline, which
was widely used in the integrated circuit
CPU designs of the 1980's.
The 5 pipeline stages correspond to the steps
of executing an instruction in a von-Neumann
stored-program architecture.
The first stage (IF) is responsible for fetching
the binary-encoded instruction from the main
memory location indicated by the program counter.
The 32-bit instruction is passed to the register
file stage (RF) where the required register
operands are read from the register file.
The operand values are passed to the ALU stage
(ALU), which performs the requested operation.
The memory stage (MEM) performs the second
access to main memory to read or write the
data for LD, LDR, or ST instructions, using
the value from the ALU stage as the memory
address.
For load instructions, the output of the MEM
stage is the read data from main memory.
For all other instructions, the output of
the MEM stage is simply the value from the
ALU stage.
In the final write-back stage (WB), the result
from the earlier stages is written to the
destination register in the register file.
Looking at the execution path from the previous
slide, we see that each of the main components
of the unpipelined design is now in its own
pipeline stage.
So the clock period will now be determined
by the slowest of these components.
Having divided instruction execution into
five stages, would we expect the clock period
to be one fifth of its original value?
Well, that would only happen if we were able
to divide the execution so that each stage
performed exactly one fifth of the total work.
In real life, the major components have somewhat
different latencies, so the improvement in
instruction throughput will be a little less
than the factor of 5 a perfect 5-stage pipeline
could achieve.
If we have a slow component, e.g., the ALU,
we might choose to pipeline that component
into further stages, or, interleave multiple
ALUs to achieve the same effect.
But for this lecture, we'll go with the 5-stage
pipeline described above.
So why isn't this a 20-minute lecture?
After all we know how pipeline combinational
circuits:
We can build a valid k-stage pipeline by drawing
k contours across the circuit diagram and
adding a pipeline register wherever a contour
crosses a signal.
What's the big deal here?
Well, is this circuit combinational?
No!
There's state in the registers and memories.
This means that the result of executing a
given instruction may depend on the results
from earlier instructions.
There are loops in the circuit where data
from later pipeline stages affects the execution
of earlier pipeline stages.
For example, the write to the register file
at the end of the WB stage will change values
read from the register file in the RF stage.
In other words, there are execution dependencies
between instructions and these dependencies
will need to be taken into account when we're
trying to pipeline instruction execution.
We'll be addressing these issues as we examine
the operation of our execution pipeline.
Sometimes execution of a given instruction
will depend on the results of executing a
previous instruction.
Two are two types of problematic dependencies.
The first, termed a data hazard, occurs when
the execution of the current instruction depends
on data produced by an earlier instruction.
For example, an instruction that reads R0
will depend on the execution of an earlier
instruction that wrote R0.
The second, termed a control hazard, occurs
when a branch, jump, or exception changes
the order of execution.
For example, the choice of which instruction
to execute after a BNE depends on whether
the branch is taken or not.
Instruction execution triggers a hazard when
the instruction on which it depends is also
in the pipeline, i.e., the earlier instruction
hasn't finished execution!
We'll need to adjust execution in our pipeline
to avoid these hazards.
Here's our plan of attack:
We'll start by designing a 5-stage pipeline
that works with sequences of instructions
that don't trigger hazards, i.e., where instruction
execution doesn't depend on earlier instructions
still in the pipeline.
Then we'll fix our pipeline to deal correctly
with data hazards.
And finally, we'll address control hazards.